ich will ihnen beiden zum schluss ein
paar fotos zeigen die kommen aus
thüringen aus neustadt und sie zeigen
schwester yvonne von einem pflegedienst
dort aus neustadt und sie fährt in diese
nordrhein sie ist die einzige moment die
in diesen abgeriegelten ort fährt der
ganz besonders schwer betroffen ist von
corona virus und sie versorgt dort die
menschen mit ihrer pflege wie wir hier
sehen und ganz genauso mit einkäufen
schwester yvonne eine wie wir finden der
korona helden dieser tage einen riesen
respekt für ihre arbeit auch für ihren
mut und dass sie die stillen helden des
alltags und im grund es sind dass in
dieser schwierigen lage genau die
vorbilder die unsere gesellschaft
braucht also herzlichen dank an die
tolle frau und ich kann ja mal ein
vorschlag machen wenn das alles vorbei
ist dann lade ich die dame für ein
wochenende in den harz das nicht so ganz
weit weg von thüringen aber trotzdem
ganz schön ein
und wie bewerten sie hier in meiner
heimatstadt großer damit sie nicht nur
dank hat sondern auch ein bisschen was
im persönlichen leben davon ist eine
tolle frau
davon gibt es ganz allein würden wieder
erlaubte es komme ich gerne dazu sowohl
super dann hat sich diese sendung
gelohnt ich danke ihnen beiden und bei
ihnen beiden besteht auch nicht die ja
dass das misstrauen dass dieses
versprechen nicht eingehalten würde
herzlichen dank und wir sehen uns morgen
wieder das war corona klartext hier bei
bild
[Musik]